ces derniers mois les Français font face
à un véritable fléau dix hommes
soupçonnés d'être impliqués dans une
escroquerie au faux conseiller bancaire
il faut conseiller bancaire chantage
arnaquevi à la carte vitale mais il est
SMS frauduleux qui paraissent pourtant
officiel les arnaques se sont récemment
multipliés si certains parviennent à
percevoir la fraude d'autres tombent
parfois dans le piège et ses arnaques
font chaque jour de nombreuses victimes
qui voient leurs coordonnées bancaires
pirater le montant total du préjudice se
sont élevé ce jour-là à
14861 euros alors pour lutter contre ce
phénomène grandissant des autorités et
le gouvernement tentent de mettre en
place un certain nombre de mesures
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République je travaille
actuellement au développement d'un
filtre anti-arnac les arnaques se
multiplient partout en France comment
les repérer et les éviter toutes les
informations ce soir dans TPMP
et terroriste Bobby est avec nous avocat
alors juste avant de parler parce que
c'est vrai que tout le monde a été plus
ou moins pas victime pas forcément mais
tout le monde a reçu au moins un message
qui était une tentative de d'escroquerie
aujourd'hui le phénomène pourquoi est-ce
qu'il s'amplifient à ce point depuis un
an c'est c'est exponenti exponentiel il
y a pas vraiment de raison pour
lesquelles le phénomène s'amplifié en
tout cas ils s'amplifient est-ce que
vous recevez aujourd'hui une quantité de
message dans des d'ailleurs sujet
totalement varié c'est-à-dire vous
pouvez recevoir des messages pour
renouveler votre carte vitale pour
acheter une vignette critique critère
vous savez pour circuler dans les zona à
faible émission des convocations de
justice vous pouvez recevoir des
convocations de justice j'ai reçu j'ai
reçu absolument j'ai reçu
c'est pas une blague
ça j'ai pas compris l'intérêt moi j'ai
reçu ça ça gendarmerie je sais pas quoi
qui me met enquête sur moi pour alors un
truc farfelu mais alors c'est assez
grossier là pour le coup vous recevez
une convocation et on vous dit voilà on
vous a attrapé et vous auriez visité un
site pédopornographique exactement et
donc on vous demande de vous rendre à
une convocation mais on peut vous dire
aussi et donc c'est écrit à la fin si
vous ne voulez pas vous rendre à la
convocation si vous voyez pas de
problème avec la justice vous devez
régler une amende depuis j'ai pas vu
donc c'est plutôt assez grossier parce
que là c'est du chanteur donc déjà on
est d'accord que déjà dans ce cas précis
nous regarde si vous recevez une
convocation la semaine dernière soit
disant policière on vous demande de
payer de payer au moment de de payer
pour ne pas aller ça n'existe pas que
lorsque vous êtes poursuivi pour des
faits pareils
c'est vous trouver et évidemment chez
vous directement à 6h une du matin
généralement il faut regarder l'adresse
mail parce que moi ça m'a fait rire du
coup j'ai regardé adresse mail faut
toujours regarder l'adresse mail qui
envoie et là c'est police à point
mette@gmail.com
dans ce cas là c'est grossi mais dans
plein d'autres cas dont on va parler le
mail est très bien fait alors il y a
combien de victimes aujourd'hui par an
on sait ou pas non c'est pas vraiment
puisque justement on essaie de les
recenser au maximum parfois les victimes
ont honte c'estiment lésés s'estiment
trompé et on parle de 61000 plaintes
quand même oui mais parfois les montants
peuvent être faibles pour quelques
centaines d'euros et donc du coup les
personnes ne veulent pas les déposer
plaindre évidemment quand c'est des
montants importants les personnes vous
portez plainte mais en tout cas on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le volume alors par
secteur mais le volume par exemple la
fraude bancaire s'élève à plus d'un
milliard d'euros en France
est-ce que le commun des mortels
classique je reçois demain ça il
m'arrive quelque chose j'ai perdu
l'argent je me suis arnaquer est-ce
qu'on est assuré pour que ça commence à
fonctionne alors on va peut-être en
parler mais les parades et commentaires
la question
est très intéressante mais elle va elle
va varier selon les cas
par rapport au nombre parce que moi ce
qu'on m'a dit c'est que pourquoi on en
reçoit de plus en plus par mail ou par
SMS c'est parce qu'il y a de plus en
plus de gens de pirates qui revendent
les numéros justement à des gens qui
après les utilisent il paraît que c'est
un marché aussi de la fraude globale qui
est en expansion totale en plus c'est
peut-être aussi une explication c'est
que chacun d'entre nous en fait de plus
en plus d'achats sur internet sur Amazon
sur des sites spécialisés etc et donc on
peut être susceptible de se faire hacker
ces données là les données bancaires le
nom prénom etc l'adresse quels sont les
arnaques les plus répandues qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qui est très à la mode
en ce moment parce que moi j'ai reçu
hanter les les
PV alors l'arnaque aujourd'hui qui est
on va dire à la mode mais en tout cas
qui fait le plus de dégâts c'est c'est
le cas que vous avez montré c'est le la
fraude au faux conseiller bancaires
alors vous avez effectivement en T donc
ce pour régler les amendes il faut
savoir que
c'est une règle de base l'État ne vous
envoie jamais de SMS pour régler une
quelconque à manque que ce soit c'est
important vous envoie des courriers ou
un huissier un huissier on vous adresse
des ATD c'est à dire des avis
directement sur votre compte bancaire on
vous envoie jamais de SMS l'État ne vous
embrasseur 11 alors je sais pas si c'est
en anglais 14h10 mais en tout cas si
c'est 2h1 du matin évidemment l'état
nous envoie pas les messages le matin
tout ce qui concerne l'état c'est pour
sauver un faux PV un impôt à payer etc
jamais jamais dans aucun cas vous payez
avec un baril comme tout le monde et
soit l'état vient prendre directement
grâce au fameux ATD à la vie à terre
détenteur qui se sert lui-même voilà
donc il y a pas de problème autre
arnaque pareil la fraude au Conseil
bancaire c'est la mode c'est un peu la
mode aujourd'hui c'est ce qui fait le
plus de dégâts puisque mon conseiller
m'appelle pour me dire j'ai besoin de
vous parler je sais que c'est pas vrai
par exemple
c'est une fraude qui est très dangereuse
parce que les le le modus operandi est
très bien monté les fraudeurs sont très
aguerris d'ailleurs il s'exprime
extrêmement bien ça vous mettre en
confiance et la plupart c'est une
personne qui vous parle vraiment ah oui
bien sûr les fameux numéro parce que des
fois on voit des numéros 08 35 et ils
ont un algorithme ça fait 35 30 il vous
rappelle 35 36 38 c'est très bien pour
vendre quelque chose ouais c'est pire
que ça c'est-à-dire que les fraudeurs
arrivent à usurper le numéro de
téléphone votre propre banque
recevez un coup de
filant mais du coup vous recevez un
fruit
et dans un cas particulier nous avons
aussi assisté à quelque chose qui peut
aussi d'ailleurs se reproduire le
fraudeur à utiliser via voilà des
applications la voix
incroyable ça ça va rejoindre le débat
d'avance sur l'intelligence artificielle
si on écarte ce point-là vous avez votre
banque vous pensez que votre banque qui
vous appelle c'est le fraudeur et là il
vous intéresse comment on fait pour
repérer exactement eu un mec qui m'a
appelé qui m'a dit c'est votre
conseiller de banque de Paris c'était un
samedi après-midi et c'est vrai que ma
banque généralement elle est ouverte le
samedi après-midi il m'a dit il y a des
mouvements anormaux il y a des
mouvements anormaux sur votre compte
qu'est-ce qu'on fait juste donnez-moi
vos codes et votre numéro pour vérifier
que c'est bien votre compte et
franchement j'ai eu la présence je sais
pas d'esprit de de ne pas lui donner et
j'ai dit mais vous êtes qui comment
est-ce que vous appelez parce que je
connais très bien mon Conseil de banque
et il m'a donné un nom qui n'était pas
du tout le bon et pour le coup là voilà
comment est-ce qu'on repère que le
conseiller c'est pas votre conseiller
vous doutez que c'est pas votre
conseiller des amis
en fait si vous voulez dans un cas dans
un dossier dans un dossier par exemple
le Conseil s'est présenté aux clients en
lui disant voilà votre conseiller donc
il lui donne le nom et le prénom de son
conseiller ce qui est quand même mis en
confiance
est absent en ce moment nous avons
repéré
est-ce que c'est vous qui êtes à
l'origine d'un paiement sur winamax
vous inquiétez pas on va réussir à
bloquer et on va rentrer dans un système
petit à petit va vous demander des
informations et vous allez entrer dans
un processus où vous allez lui ouvrir
des informations
niveau code internet jamais niveau code
de carte bleue encore moins et il y a un
numéro de carte et un numéro de
téléphone qui est derrière la carte
bleue pour tout ce qui est fraude et
quand vous appelez tout est stoppé donc
si vous avez un problème chez vous et
que voilà vous découvrez que ça peut
arriver parce que tout le monde s'est
fait au moins pirater une fois sur une
carte bleue voilà donc on appelle la
banque rembourse généralement en un mois
oui oui et non il y a ça se traite très
très bien non mais c'est surtout que
lorsque vous êtes piraté lorsque du
moins il y a des mouvements frauduleux
sur votre compte votre compte bancaire
peut vous appeler pour vous demander si
vous êtes à l'origine et si vous n'êtes
pas l'origine il annule point il vous
demande pas d'information particulière
sur on peut vous demander des
informations de sécurité mais
généralement votre conseiller bancaire
vous le demande jamais jamais et à aucun
moment
avec les les sites en ligne maintenant
vous avez ce qu'on appelle le Securitas
il vous demande il fait une opération il
vous demande de la valider depuis votre
ordinateur donc il y a zéro de notre
possible
mais effectivement c'est hyper bien fait
ce que vous dites et souvent aussi c'est
via Paypal moi c'était avec paypal ou
justement on m'a appelé on m'a dit voilà
je travaille dans votre banque je
remplace madame machin il connaissait le
nom truc non et c'est vraiment vraiment
bien foutu et après quand vous avez le
vrai banquier au téléphone et vous
l'insulte vous n’hésitez pas à vous
voilà bon faut faire attention
j'ai mon vrai banquier m'a appelé me dit
vous vous venez d'acheter pour 15000
euros de montres boulevard Saint-Germain
non dans trois boutiques je dis non
monsieur ah ben un dialogue
on m'a fait un doublon de de ma carte et
il y a un mec qui est quand même aller
dans trois bijouteries dans la même
après-midi acheter à 15000 euros de
montre ah c'était c'était une grosse
c’était quand même Jean-Marie une grosse
carte quand même parce que assez une
carte infinie
allez c'est pas la Visa bleu pourri la
jeans c'est pas hein
c'est que le commerçant il doit pouvoir
savoir que ce n'est pas la carte du mec
qui est tu peux
production est très souvent ils
acceptent ce qu'ils font une vente et
puis en fait le mec bah lui il a montré
la revanche dans l'après-midi moitié
prix ainsi de suite alors qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme comme on a avancé
j'aimerais juste répondre à votre
question sinon c'est pas grave je
voudrais pas mettre dans l'embrasse
responsabilité
le principe est que la présence
exactement il y a une présomption qui
pèse sur la banque puisque vous avez
confié votre argent à la banque et donc
elle est censée vous rembourser sauf que
il y a une exception si vous avez
négligé gravement à votre obligation
également de vigilance de secret de
secret si vous avez vous-même un escroc
donnez vos informations personnelles
confidentiel la banque peut engager
votre responsabilité du moins vous
pouvez du coup ne pas être lassé le
chien qui se mord la queue parce que si
on a c'est la voix qui a été changé
j'ai vu les arnaques avec la carte
Vitale ah ça c'est quoi ça c'est
incroyable sur les banques je connais
moi trois personnes différentes qui sont
fait
de cette façon donc c'est très très
répandu et vous disiez que c'est les
gens qui achètent beaucoup en ligne par
exemple ma mère ça lui arrivait elle
achèterait rien du tout donc il faut
vraiment tout le monde se méfie tout le
temps alors donc la carte Vitale c'est
tout le monde moi j'ai reçu aussi alors
la carte Vitale c'est quelque chose qui
m'a fait sourire puisque on vous demande
de régler quelques centimes pour mettre
à jour votre carte Vitale donc
évidemment c'est pour récupérer vous
donner bancaire je pense qu'on va être
assez d'impôts pour que la carte Vitale
puisse être renouvelée gratuitement j'ai
eu un appel d'abord demandé si mon
adresse avait changé donc en fait il
vous il vous en ruban au début et après
ils appartient l'adresse hameçonnage
c'est là où vous êtes fatigué en fait
social est de 45 milliards merci
c'est-à-dire c'est plus que le budget de
l'armée française merci augmenter pour
ça il faudrait juste simplement demander
plus de la carte demander la carte
d'identité et bien en économiserait déjà
20 milliards merci merci que chacun seul
on peut on peut la mettre à jour dans
une importation
l'arnaque et la Française des jeux c'est
quoi ça l'arnaque la France ah oui bien
sûr l'arnaque Française des jeux vous
recevez un message pour vous dire que
vous êtes le regagnant d'une somme
importante et que donc vous devez
cliquer sur un lien pour venir récupérer
votre chèque
il faut vraiment
vous êtes millionnaire ah bon
une arnaque qui peut
pour ceux qui comptent beaucoup sur
Amazon par exemple ou sur n'importe quel
autre site de vente en ligne sont les
textos que vous recevez pour récupérer
votre colis
alors il y a Chronopost et DHL c'est ça
ça peut être très piège alors
généralement vous demande de régler une
petite partie pour les problèmes de
douane
il y a ça il y a aussi traquer votre
l'avancée de votre collier alors donc ça
on aurait on ne traque pas c'est la
fonction existe sur les vrais sites
exactement alors ça ce sont des méthodes
qui sont assez délicates à contourner
parce que comme vous le dites DHL par
exemple qui propose le très gros
il y a des vrais textos aussi donc moi
je vais plus rien chercher rien nulle
part je te laisse tout bah c'est fini
tu payes tu vas pas
ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive
pas
c'est quoi la meuf l'arnaque aux fan de
célébrités
courante chez les arnaqueurs qui
s'approprient de personnalité célèbre et
arnaque ainsi leur fans par exemple moi
j'ai un compte Instagram grâce à moi je
vais vous faire gagner un téléphone
portable alors je vous rassure ça
n'arrivera jamais de base mais mais
c'est vrai alors il y a des comptes avec
Amélie c'est-à-dire celle qui prend les
rendez-vous c'est moi qui vais
alors juste il y a des copains TPMP il y
a des concours c'est organisé c'est
carrément c'est pas Cyril Hanouna qui
vous dit je vais vous faire gagner un
téléphone voilà donc
jamais non plus
jamais très bien qu'est-ce qu'elle veut
comme très répandu en tout cas et je
vous vois peut-être une parenthèse
lorsqu'on est victime d'une arnaque le
le premier réflexe de recueillir le
maximum d'informations vraiment le
maximum
contextualisé et adress directement une
plainte soit procureur de la République
directement une pleine contre X je ne
connais pas
non non c'est un courrier que vous avez
rédigé
la plupart du temps c'est pas un avocat
lorsque vous adressez une plainte au
procure la République c'est plutôt
conseillé ou alors vous allez
directement à votre commissariat du coin
ça protège pour les remportements aussi
tout ça tout de suite il faut porter
plainte tout de suite il faut agir
et parce que beaucoup de temps juste
c'est quoi les frais d'avocation
ils sont mal un peu c'est si je vais
vous voir pour une problème d'arnaque
c'est les honoraires peuvent être
extrêmement élevés oh il est fort
d'accord écoutez en tous les cas en
résumé en résumé de nous donner jamais
en résumé de ne jamais vos codes ni de
carte bancaire ni de site bancaire voilà
les cartes vitales on vous demandera
jamais rien en échange qui vous appelle
c'est peut-être pas lui et si vous avez
en gros ne répondez plus jamais au
téléphone voilà